[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance buried in another disastrous
poll for Donald Trump this one from ABC
News and The Washington Post buried
behind those two organizations idea of
the headline namely that a years since
his election 65 percent of Americans
believe Trump has so far accomplished
little buried is one heartbreaking
earth-shaking statistic while his
support from his red meat hallucinatory
base is collapsing it's down by 18
points among all conservatives down by
15 points among working-class white
women down by 13 points among
independents by 12 among men by 11 among
whites even with the ground beneath him
transforming into quicksand ABC and the
post found that of those who say they
voted for Trump ninety-one percent say
they would still support him that is
heartbreaking it's not heartbreaking
that it's that high it's not
heartbreaking that only 9% can't say
they would still support him it's
heartbreaking that those nine percent
who would no longer support him could
not have been convinced of the reality
that lay ahead before they voted a year
ago a year ago right now that seemingly
tiny number nine percent who would not
vote for Trump today would have been
enough to prevent this to prevent the
greatest tragedy in American history a
year ago in Wisconsin Donald Trump got 1
million four hundred and five thousand
two hundred and eighty four votes and
Hillary Clinton got 1 million three
hundred and eighty two thousand five
hundred and thirty six votes reduce his
vote total by nine percent give none of
his votes to Clinton just imagine they
voted for Stein or Johnson or castle or
McMullen or Morehead or de la fuente or
they stayed home and Trump gets just 1
million two hundred and seventy eight
thousand eight hundred and eight votes
Trump loses Wisconsin by nearly one
hundred and four thousand a year ago in
Michigan Donald Trump got two million
two hundred and seventy nine thousand
five hundred forty three votes and
Hillary Clinton got two million two
hundred and sixty eight thousand eight
hundred thirty nine votes reduce his
vote total by nine
give none of his votes to Clinton just
imagine they voted for Stein or Johnson
or castle or McMullen or solty sick or
they stayed home and Trump gets just two
million seventy four thousand three
hundred and eighty four votes Trump
loses Michigan by more than a hundred
ninety four thousand a year ago in
Pennsylvania Donald Trump got two
million nine hundred and seventy
thousand seven hundred thirty three
votes and Hillary Clinton got two
million nine hundred twenty-six thousand
four hundred and forty one votes reduced
his total by nine percent give none of
his votes to Clinton just imagine they
voted for Stein or Johnson or Castle or
they stayed home and Trump gets just two
million seven hundred and three thousand
three hundred and sixty seven votes
Trump loses Pennsylvania by more than
two hundred twenty-three thousand and a
year ago in Florida Donald Trump got
four million six hundred and seventeen
thousand eight hundred and eighty six
votes and Hillary Clinton got four
million five hundred four thousand nine
hundred seventy five reduce his vote
total by nine percent give none of his
votes to Clinton just imagine they voted
for Stein or Johnson or castle or dear
la fuente or they stayed home and Trump
gets just four million two hundred and
two thousand two hundred and seventy six
votes Trump loses Florida by nearly
three hundred and three thousand votes
the math is inescapable Wisconsin was
worth ten Michigan was worth sixteen
electoral college votes to trump
Pennsylvania 20 Florida 29 if the tiny
number nine percent of Trump voters who
would not support him today had a year
ago known better were reasoned better or
voted an election not swayed or sabotage
or colluded against or stolen by another
country if they had not voted for him
those 75 electoral college votes would
have gone to Hillary Clinton and she
would have been elected president by a
vote of three hundred and seven to
Trump's 233 no nightmare no national
tragedy no jeopardizing of every freedom
we have and of course the reality is
it's even just a little worse than that
cut Trump's vote by 9% nationwide and he
loses Arizona and he loses North
Carolina and he even loses one of the
five electoral votes in Nebraska and the
final tally in the electoral college is
Clinton 334 Trump 204 a larger margin to
votes more than Obama got against Romney
and these people who have put this
monster in office and will if not
stopped ruin this country would have
scurried back into their sewers and we
would be America again
but as sad as this one seemingly
insignificant overlooked poll number
might be consider the upside if those 9%
of Trump voters knew then what they know
now we would have a different president
well they know now don't they and with
them let us get ourselves a different
president resist remove peace my book
based on these commentaries is available
now online and at booksellers 7 weeks to
Christmas just saying